l'atteinte aux papin c'est la spécialité
d'un village du pas-de-calais qui
s'appelle hui ruine et qui est située en
bordure de la forêt de boulogne et c'est
votre mère monsieur le maire de
wirwignes c'est votre mère qui a lancé
ses deux spécialités
oui il ya longtemps elle ya 61 ans en
au lendemain de la guerre dans quelles
circonstances
lorsqu'elle a repris le café était
exploité par ses beaux-parents l'époque
elle a créé cette d'artaud ben on crée
je suis peut-être beaucoup dire qu elle
a peut-être améliorer la à lannion 22
courses et elle l'a rendue populaire anp
du diamant du populaire car il a
énormément de succès ce dessert
aujourd'hui ici oui oui certainement
énormément de succès alors voilà la
tarte papa qu'est ce que c'est
exactement la perte probable si tu te
tarte à la crème de quoi et avec des
avec des produits nous et c'est votre
épouse aujourd'hui qui maintiennent la
tradition qui maintient la tradition oui
parce qu'elle vient aider ici chez
monsieur madame boucher elle l'a fait
pendant à peu près 25 ans avec moment et
maintenant elle continue encore après le
décès de membres alors là vous voyez le
four on est en train de l'allumer il
faut à peu près deux heures de chauffe
pour faire chauffer le four pour faire
la terre tu on à tarte aux papas qui est
faite d'une façon traditionnelle depuis
depuis une cinquantaine d'années plus de
50 ans par manas marley par mme et mr
comme on l'appelait et mémère faisait
cette tarte dance floor qui est qui et
même centenaire dans lost un film qui a
été fait auprès d'eux une quinzaine une
quinzaine d'années et ça montre
exactement comment exposer le maire
mémère harlé puisque mémère harlé était
filmé dans dans ce petit film et on voit
l'arrière-plan la poste c'est la dame
qui détourne avec la grande pelle c'est
sa belle fille qui continuent à venir
faire la terre qui vont tous les
week-ends
et les deux autres dames sont
pratiquement presque aussi âgé que
mémère harlé enfin une dizaine d'années
- cesson c'était 2 mai mais aussi qu'ils
venaient et des grands mères pour pour
faire la terre il va là marley à
l'époque de ces de ces images mais mère
elle avait à peu près dans la voix s'il
avait à peu près 80 2 ans puisqu'elle a
quitté le commerce à 80 84 ans et
elle se servait comme vous voyez d'une
d'une bouteille parce qu'à l'époque
évidemment il y avait quand même des
rouleaux à pâtisserie mais elle avait
fait la terre pendant plus de 50 ans
avec une bouteille
elle continuait toujours à étaler la
pâte avec sa bouteille
et c'était la sienne particulièrement
fait l'école fallait pas essayer de la
rouler en lui donnant une autre
bouteille parce qu'elle avait sa
bouteille
[Musique]
le four est chauffée donc pendant deux
heures et quand on voit que le four et
chaussées qu' il est tout blanc
c'est-à-dire qui scintille comme de
petites étoiles alors là on enlève le
bois rond c'est à dire qu'on des braises
on enlève tout les braises dans ce dans
cet entonnoir mais dans ce pot qui en
dessous d'entonnoir et là on enfourne on
à peu près 30 à 32 tarte par fournées et
on continue tous les tous les week-ends
donc depuis 60 ans à faire cette tarte
tous les week-ends et le goût et
particuliers aussi puisque la crème est
saisie c'est à dire que la crème reste
crème ne durcit pas le papa reste
présomptueux très très crémeux et le
papa à un petit arrière goût de feu de
bois
c'est lol la particularité
[Musique]
mais la tarte au pape un peu ce cuir
aussi dans un four normal four de
cuisinière et vous avez une constaté
d'ailleurs en suivant chez la belle
fille de madame à avoir mal à parler
vous allez vous faire la tarte papin
pour combien de personnes pour 10
personnes monsieur à condition que
chacun de marche un quartier habité mais
c'est si bon je suppose que souvent on
comprendra alors quels sont les
proportions à respecter pour faire cette
tarte
alors pour la crème on commence on
commence par faire la crème 1 ligue 2
les albums et la 50 g de farine 50 g de
maïzena 150 g de sucre et 2 28 et 2
bâtons vanille dans le lait pour
parfumer pour parfumer pour la trame de
11,8 ici pour la pâte 50 g de sucre en
poudre 50 g de beurre 150 g de farine 2
e et un petit peu de salim passer de
celle d'accord de brûlots au sujet des
pruneaux pour mettre dans la crème quand
la pâte est terminée et la crème et mise
sur la sur la tarte et ce morceau de
pâte qu'est ce que c'est c'est la pâte
feuilletée
c'est pour faire les garnitures de la
perte alors que vous faites maintenant
je fais bouillir mans léman sucre et la
vanille des grands morceaux ou sucre en
poudre ont pas d'appartement
alors je m'en vais simplement qu'ils
lire bon de l'est et tiède
qu'est ce que vous faites tout ensemble
mettez les au lanthier doux
et vous mélangez pas facile de lier tous
à un bon mondial et quart avec vigueur
faut battre pour défendre tient une
sorte de crème ou verser venez dessus
petit à petit ah bon vous allez faire
prendre la crise pousse à un petit peu
la foi une foi dans un sens ou dans
l'autre où m un amant ou mettez pas tous
le litre vous allez me l'a même pas oui
même pas d'accord voilà les abris s'est
pas enfui et vous mélangez dans votre
préparation préparation avec deux ailes
en agitant comme ça vigoureusement pitot
soient bromont très bien bon alors la
crème épaisse qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on
laisse refroidir
maintenant on va faire la paix vous
prenez une petite quinzaine
je mets mon père la crème 40 g de crème
de lait oui que je fais cendres là alors
je pars à la fin de mon père et ma crème
d'accord sur le gaz une petit peu de sel
et vous mélangez le beurre et la crème
fondu avec la farine par vous avez un
petit creux
au milieu l'appareil dans lequel vous
mettez les autres 2e encore une fois et
je vais les petits morceaux de levure
d'un petit peu d'eau hamon vous écrasez
la levure de boulanger alors là vous
mélangez à la main toujours à la main
alors là c'est le principe de tout les
patins il faut que ce soit bien homogène
c'est ça donc il faut de la poignée
c'est ça que j'ai comme pat c'est une
pâte l'oser bombardier avait prête pas
ce que vous en faites de votre pote
vraiment je vais étaler ma patte sur la
turque est ça va mieux avec une
bouteille beaucoup mieux il faut une
bouteille de bordeaux pour qu'elles les
apports des hologrammes la tourtière et
aux coupes les bords s'ajouter la crème
maquerelle qui est froid de là vous
l'avez blizzard a refroidi les refroidir
dans un récipient bonne couche fine
couche vous ne faites pas lever la patte
à ras non il va lever dans le four à
l'appui ce sens juridique rio
pourquoi je vais faire les garnitures
alors là vous reprenez la même pâte pour
les garnitures fait deux très fines 3
dans le sens étroit dans l'autre on
forme de petits logements beau vous
n'avez rien changé à la recette de votre
belle-mère n'ai pas essayé de la
moderniser non pas du tout c'est trop
bon comme ça pourquoi vous mettez la
pâte feuilletée la mort plutôt que de la
pâte levée comme l'autre parce que sa
bru n'a pas de citer le poulpe doré un
petit peu avec un jaune d'oeuf
c'est terminé
alors vous allez laisser la tarte au
four combien de temps 45 minutes
monsieur avec un four à combien à 9
thermostat 9,49 à bien et après on
pourra les déguster
et surtout ne prenez pas de cuiller à
bombe à vous affirmer non il faut la
manger avec les doigts avec les doigts
bien meilleure bon mais on pourrait
aussi bien l'appeler la datar de manama
relais cet art pop 1 parce que c'est
c'est vraiment votre mère qui s'appelait
manama relais qui l'a rendue populaire
oui bien sûr pour beaucoup c'est la tare
de madame harley ou la tarte de louise
puisqu'elle s'appuie louise
ah oui elle est restée dans la mémoire
de tous les gens ici au village
ah oui oui oui ça a été une grande
figure ci était d'une grande figure vous
voulez peut-être voir sa photo à
saint-prex plaisir oui à oui biensur
beau sourire et le chignon un de
toujours voilà madame années avant la
guerre on buvait du si dans papa faisait
du cidre bouché du cidre pétillant
là on a de la bière la bière du verre à
bière de garde en appel cette bière
boucher 1 c'est différent de la part de
certaines spécialités du nord
[Musique]
merci bien et bon appétit
la pythie c'est très bon voilà parler la
crèmerie
[Musique]